this episode was sponsored by blinkist
blinkist puts all of the need to know
information from
thousands of non-fiction books and
condenses them down to just 15 minutes
and you can go to blinkist.com
microcosmos
to learn more
recently we did our first ever journey
to the micro cosmos live stream some of
you may even have been there
whether that's because you wanted to see
the microbes that james our master of
microscopes was showing live from his
microscope
or because he wanted to see our faces to
be honest we'd understand if you were
there mostly for the microbes but
whatever the reason thank you for
joining us the real highlight though for
all of us was a moment that combined the
best
of microbes and faces it is this moment
right here that look on james's face
when he realized that something very
exciting had just appeared on the screen
here i'll just play it and you can
experience the excitement again in real
time
wow guys we've documented something
probably never reported from euro what
is that
um this is a common microorganisms
called
uh but this species
with endosymbiotic algae it was never
like oh my god sorry
science is happening live and in in the
moment
right now the thing that had james so
excited was that green
glow-stick looking ciliate called
spirostumum semi-varescens
it's a large ciliate he had been working
to find for over
three years and it just happened to show
up
during our live stream his mentor
professor hanover esteban was watching
the live stream from the uk
where she works at bournemouth
university and when the moment of
recognition hit both her
and james she texted omg followed by
approximately 14 exclamation points
look 2021 has been a strange year
and the pandemic has led to lots of
changes in how we
share and talk about things but there is
some joy to be had in the fact that we
could
share this moment as a community spread
all around the world
all of us peering through a microscope
as james guided us through what we were
seeing
but of course the real question here is
why were james and his professor
so excited well there are currently
eight known spirostomums in the world
their bodies
all long and contractile and twisty
some of these specimens can grow as much
as four millimeters in length making
them both
visible to the naked eye and potentially
easy to confuse with worms
and while some of these species are
abundant spirostomumum semivarescens
has been a much rarer find it's
surprising when you look at it after all
this is a two millimeter long bright
green
ciliate slithering through a field of
smaller organisms and debris
it's just so glaringly there how could
it be difficult to find
well according to the reported
observations pretty difficult
there's a record from germany dating
back to 1852.
and in 2009 professor esteban and her
team recorded their presence for the
first time
in the uk in 2015 they followed that up
with a study of spirostomum
semivarescens
found in two swedish ponds one in
farmland
and the other in an ancient forest
now it's hard to pin down exactly why
this species might be so rare
some microbes are just like that
probably because they're particular
about what kind of
light or food they like to have around
them
the thing about being rare though is
that sure
might take a while to find a spot where
the organism likes to live but once you
find their home
they can turn out to be fairly abundant
we talk about ponds
like their one big habitat but for
microbes
they're actually many many many habitats
stacked on top of and below and around
each other
with fuzzy boundaries defined by
chemical gradients and temperature
changes and
physical entities that create many
different types of homes
that suit many different types of
organisms
and so finding organisms like
spirostomum semivarescens
can sometimes be a matter of sampling
many different places
or it can be a matter of sampling the
same site
over and over again either way
microscopy rewards the patient and
diligent
and the rarity of spirostomum
semivarescens is made all the more
interesting
because of its size
[Music]
there's this idea in microbiology maybe
you've even heard of it
everything is everywhere but the
environment
selects that phrase was coined by the
dutch microbiologist lorenz gm
bass becking in 1934. beckingh himself
was drawing on the work of another dutch
microbiologist
named martinus b drink who had observed
that using
different culture conditions allowed him
to isolate
different types of bacteria from his
samples when extended beyond the
confines of a lab culture the premise
is this microbes are tiny
like super small right but they're also
able to form
very large populations growing massive
in number
if small in size and as a result of
their small size in large populations
not to mention their ability to form
protective cysts
it is not hard for microbes to disperse
and spread there are many of them they
can stick to the legs of
ducks and turtles they can blow on the
wind
we find the same species of microbes all
around the world they find it easy to
move around
but of course not everything is actually
everywhere
how could they be when there are so many
different types of places to be
well that's where the second half of the
hypothesis comes in
but the environment selects
the microbes may disperse easily and
spread widely
but what survives is the result of the
many environmental factors they land in
but of course there are limits to this
microbes find it easy to move around
kangaroos do not there's a size
at which it gets more difficult to be
everywhere
spirostomum semi-veressen's large size
makes it an exciting organism to
consider
against this idea of everything being
everywhere because it's
like pushing the limit of what makes a
microbe easy to disperse
and that makes the discovery of the
species at distant
ponds all the more compelling
[Music]
but while everything is everywhere but
the environment selects may just be a
single sentence
the debate it has inspired has spanned
many decades worth of research papers
there are other scientists who have
reported that bacteria appear to be
rendered
distinct by their location making their
biology
a function not just of environment but
of whatever history
separated them from other similar
species
the nuances of how to think about and
interpret
everything is everywhere but the
environment selects is itself
a reflection of just how remarkable
microbes are and also the dialogue
that shapes science over long periods of
time
and while our spirostomum semivarescens
cannot bring the conversation to a close
we are excited to have been able to
interrupt it for a moment
with just a little bit of new
information
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us and also to those of you
who were there for this moment on our
journey
as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us
so how's that 2021 reading list coming
along you finding yourself
distracted maybe just too busy to sit
down and read
all of the books you've been meaning to
get to thankfully
blinkist is here to help you learn new
things
in just a little bit of time blinkist
highlights the most
important insights and need to know
information from non-fiction books
and condenses them down so that you can
either read or listen to them
in just 15 minutes and if you're looking
to learn even more about
wiggly weird things that live in water
you might like to check out the book of
eels by patrick svensson
which is available on blinkist seriously
eels
are very weird we're still not even
really 100 sure where and how they mate
you're going to want to learn more about
eels whether you're interested in
science
history or business blinkist has
something for you in the 3
000 plus non-fiction titles in their
library
and if you're one of the first 100
people to sign up today at blinkist.com
microcosmos you can get free unlimited
access for seven days and you'll also
get 25
off if you decide to get a full
membership
we also of course need to thank today
and also every other day
our patrons on patreon you're seeing
some of their names on the screen right
now and without them
this show could not exist so if you like
the show and you want to help us
continue making it
you can join all of those amazing people
at patreon.com
journeytomicro if you'd like to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can follow him at jam
and germs on instagram and if you'd like
to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you